all right pft pm posse mailbag it's been
200 or more days since we've last heard
from jerry jones is this a record
shireen
when do you expect us to hear from him
again now we saw him
buying wine at a 7-eleven a few weeks
ago but we haven't heard from him what
are we gonna hear from this guy
it's been forever mike they're required
to do a press conference with the gm
which he is the gm before the draft so i
expect that week before the draft the
next time we'll hear from jerry jones
this absolutely is the longest he's ever
gone without a press conference i
guarantee you and i guarantee you he
missed it and i guarantee you he can't
wait to talk and when he does finally
talk that thing could go on for hours
mike
now we do hear from him twice a week
during the season on 105.3 the fan in
dallas so he hasn't exactly been hiding
under a rock but i know from the cowboys
games that you attend it's always
appointment
viewing and listening when he holds
court with with reporters after the game
and talks for 25 or 30 minutes and we
were without that this year because the
pandemic fred the great where is the
best place for vikings defensive end to
neil hunter what would they want in
return look i don't know they're even
going to trade him i think the best
place for him is minnesota they had no
pass rush without him last year last
year he wasn't happy with his contract
and he had that tweak as mike zimmer
called it well the tweak ended up
knocking him out for the year because he
had some sort of a disc issue in his
neck i just hope he's healthy for his
sake and he can get back to being the
guy that he was but i think once joey
bosa got that 27 million dollar per year
contract that's when hunter got very
upset with his deal that pays about half
that i don't know that the vikings would
even be comfortable adjusting it until
they know he's healthy i think the best
thing for him to do now is reestablish
himself and then hope the vikings find a
way to take care of him
and maybe they have a handshake wink
wink hey show us in 2021 that you're
healthy and we promise to redo your
contract or trade you or make it work
out for you after this season if we
can't pay you
because he showed mike for two years
there he was one of the best edge
rushers in football he's still only 26.
they try to trade this guy they're gonna
get nothing for him right now i mean
he's worth probably two first rounders
but are you giving up two first rounders
to get him when he's coming off a neck
injury no i don't think so so the best
place for him this year is minnesota go
prove it again and then you'll get paid
next year
brad dugan87 what are the chances the
panthers land to sean watson or trade up
for a quarterback in the draft look i
think whatever they do david tepper the
owner of the team a man who is used to
getting what he wants and has the money
to get what he needs and then some he
wants a franchise quarterback and he
seems hell bent shireen on getting one
deshaun watson a target moving up in the
draft a target who knows how high they'd
have to go but he wants that guy who is
going to be the transformational
quarterback that leads that team into a
future of being a contender year in and
year out he has his coach he has his gm
and now he wants his quarterback and i
would not bet against david tepper when
it comes to a guy
used to getting his way getting his way
and getting a franchise quarterback
somehow someway this off season
we know deshaun watson makes so much
sense from the fact that he played at
clemson those fans would go ballistic
they would sell out that stadium it
would be great for carolina i don't know
how deshawn watson feels about carolina
he has the no trade claws and i just
think that houston is going to screw
this thing up so to me the best course
of action for carolina is to evaluate
these quarterbacks and if you like one
at eight you take him he's your guy
or you just wait out the texans you
assume they eventually are going to
screw it up and realize too late what
they could have done and maybe you could
get to sean watson later david tepper
has to at least be thinking of that
possibility that in failing to maximize
the return they could get now for
deshaun watson if you're patient there's
an opportunity to swoop in and get
deshawn watson later when maybe there's
no one else who's in the running for
deshawn watson be right shereen he's got
to want to go to carolina and wave is no
trade clause for that to occur uh so
either way whoever it is i think they're
going to find a way to get a guy that
they believe is a franchise quarterback
all sports global if you were the
seahawks sheree what would you want
for a russell wilson trade
it'd take a lot mike and it's going to
hurt whoever trades for him you know we
talked about chicago it's going to take
colomak and at least two first rounders
maybe three i mean he's that good that
it's gonna hurt you to trade for him and
you're gonna have to figure out how to
build around him without much draft
capital but it's gonna take a lot mike
if you give me khalil mack the 20th
overall pick in the draft and next
year's first rounder for the bears i
think i take it if i acknowledge the
fact that at some point this ship is
running aground with russell wilson and
it's getting closer and closer to the
rocks i'm going to take that and move on
gets back to what i always say they
don't view him the way he views him
somebody else views him the way he views
him that someone else is going to make
an offer that the seahawks will say hell
yeah we'll take that three first-round
picks maybe more maybe some players
whatever the case may be
i i i just feel like it's inevitable and
it makes sense to do it now and not have
it hover over the team for the entire 21
season real quickly going deep your
thoughts on juju smith schuster or zac
ertz to baltimore shereen
well i think they need some help mike
this is a an offense that the receiving
corps ranked last in every category
they've got to get some wide-outs
however they do that willis needs a free
agent dez bryant and coming back
hollywood brown has been okay but he
hasn't been great so they've got to
improve at that position however they do
it mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports